we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors nebia is a revolutionary shower
head that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman blinkist is the app that helps
you become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
steady md lets you maintain a meaningful
long lasting relationship with a primary
care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99
a month with no other fees or copays
visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started all right welcome
everybody our last show before the
thanksgiving break a few disclaimers
before we start
i'm feeling fine i appreciate the
messages of concern
continuing to pour in i sound different
this week if you're listening because
i'm in a different location different
microphone
i look different because of different
lighting and i'm sort of in front of a
weird window
but i'm fine it's just the lighting i've
not gone pale
or red or whatever people are worried
about i appreciate the concern i'm
feeling fine
heading into the thanksgiving holiday
hopefully
safely and a few things i want to talk
about with you
today before we go on our brief
thanksgiving break
first of all uh now that donald trump
has come as close as he is likely to get
to conceding this election to joe biden
the transition has officially started
even though it had started already but
now it's
really started we must focus on the two
georgia senate runoffs as the
primary focus of the next roughly eight
weeks and well actually
it's eight weeks until biden is sworn in
uh but it's only about six weeks until
these runoffs
on january 5th there will be two runoff
elections in georgia which will
determine
do republicans control the senate for
joe biden's first two years
or do democrats control the senate for
joe biden's first two years
one race is incumbent republican david
perdue
versus democratic challenger john ossoff
the other race is republican incumbent
kelly loffler one of the most corrupt
senators in the senate versus democratic
challenger rafael
warnock these will be tough races but
they are winnable races and we have to
understand
it'll be tough but we can win both ideas
we can hold
at the same time the loffler versus
warnock race is reportedly a one point
race
some polls say it's loffler plus one
others say it's warnock plus one what
does this mean
i'll wait you know i don't have to tell
you everybody
who votes in georgia must vote legal
votes obviously
um it's basically a tie the other race
perdue versus assaf
also right in there the late we have we
have uh only one recent poll from last
week which says it's 49.49
previous polls showed that purdue uh was
a little bit ahead by
three or even as many as four points
it's a statistical tie
right now they are uphill battles the
path forward
is putting all of our effort into these
races
anybody who wants to phone bank can
phone bank donate
if you can afford to pandemic safe door
knocking
is being organized in georgia if you are
in georgia
voter registration including the work of
stacy
abrams could be the difference maker
here
her work has been unbelievable and on
the other side
there this is this is more funny because
it's so self-defeating than anything
else
there are some republicans that are so
mad
at trump uh and other republicans
for i guess not fighting more to steal
the presidency from joe biden
that there are some republicans in
georgia saying
boycott the senate runoff just don't go
and vote
and to them i say what a great idea i
hope that that's exactly what you do
help us defeat those incumbent
republicans
uh uh we we really cannot overstate the
importance
of these races if assaf and warnock
win it's 50 50 in the senate that makes
kamala harris the deciding vote
this means tax reform might be done
this means health care expansion might
be done
maybe infrastructure and more now
they will all be battles understand that
even with control of the senate
you will still be up against the more
centrist wing
of the democratic party but these become
battles worth fighting
i believe and i know some people say
david you're being too pessimistic
i believe that without the senate none
of this gets done i just don't see how
you do tax reform and health care
expansion
and infrastructure the way joe biden
wants to do it focused on clean green
energy
i don't see how you do it without the
senate um if if
the democrats are not able to win those
two seats
joe biden will be relegated to governing
at least for two years
essentially by executive order on all
but the most
uncontroversial things and remarkably
little will get done
in terms of big legislation so this is
where the focus has to be
and meanwhile donald trump really seems
to be running out of gas let's discuss
that next
donald trump has still not taken
questions from reporters
it's been about a month now it's been
since before the election that we have
not actually
seen donald trump take questions from
reporters
yesterday suddenly haphazardly
a presidential press conference was
called it was in the briefing room
at the white house and it lasted this is
not a mistake
okay 64 seconds
not minutes 64 seconds
is all that it was assembling the press
corps
for donald trump to take no questions
and delusionally brag about medical
advancements and the dow jones
industrial average
hitting 30 000 during trading yesterday
take a look at this
now normally i say this thing went on an
hour
it went on an hour and a half i can't
play the whole thing for you
i am playing the entire press conference
for you today okay not a portion of it
let's start
well thank you very much and i just want
to congratulate everybody
the stock market dow jones industrial
average just hit 30 000 which is the
highest in history
we've never broken 30 000 and that's
just despite
everything that's taken place with the
pandemic i'm very
thrilled with what's happened on the
vaccine front that's been
absolutely incredible i find it sort of
hilarious
that donald trump comes in and says he
wants to congratulate everybody
congratulate everybody for doing what
exactly i mean just a bizarre
start a comedy of errors like every
little detail is hilarious and pathetic
that was the first 23 seconds of the
64. let's now get to more of this we're
i'm showing you everything we're going
to pick it up right where we left off
it's nothing like that has ever happened
medically
and i think people are acknowledging
that and it's having a big effect but
the stock market's just broken thirty
thousand never been broken that number
that's a sacred number thirty thousand
nobody thought they'd ever see it
okay i i have to stop once more
30 000 is a sacred number what
what is he talking about how is that
even a remotely sensible thing to say
it's sacred to get to thirty thousand
what
i don't even know what that's supposed
to mean and then here are the last 25
seconds
uh that's the ninth time since uh
the beginning of 2020 and it's the 48th
time that we've broken records in
during the trump administration and i
just want to congratulate all the people
within the administration that worked so
hard
and most importantly i want to
congratulate the people of our country
because there are no people like you
thank you very much everybody thank you
so that is the full press conference
64 seconds with mike pence
standing behind him with this kind of
doofy smirk
on his face to say congratulations to
the american people
i guess for hitting the sacred number
of 30 000 in the dow jones industrial
average and to claim
that we've seen medical advancements
like we've never seen before
thanks to his presidency and to still
take no
questions how bizarre is this this i
you know i am uh i am not a person who
lacks empathy
donald trump seems seems unable to
experience the feeling of empathy i
i don't lack empathy and in watching
these very sad 64 seconds
i actually came close to thinking about
maybe feeling slightly bad for trump
just deflated grasping for
anything that he can say or do to
keep his grip on relevance as the
transition to joe biden's presidency
continues and it seems like trump feels
it slipping away like
grant grains on a sandy beach slipping
through one's fingers
it's strange to see donald trump keep
trying to sell himself to the american
people after losing
an election and one other funny note
back during the transition period
into trump's administration donald trump
took credit for the rise in the stock
market
in november and december and early
january
remember barack obama was still
president then but donald trump took
credit and said
no no once i got elected stocks started
going up even before i was inaugurated
thanks to me
that's the opposite of what he's doing
here he is now
saying even though the stock market is
going up
after joe biden has been elected
he as the lame duck president still gets
credit for the stock market going up
at this point you know hypocrisy is dead
and double standards have no meaning
with this administration
but just sort of like as a side note
outgoing here
um not even worth arguing with him not
even worth arguing with trumpists about
you know don't let the door hit you on
the way out but yet
another one of these instances of donald
trump holding himself
to a completely different standard than
he held barack obama to and that applies
to joe biden and that applies to hillary
clinton and it applies to
uh essentially anybody that would be
seen as not
friendly to donald trump in the space of
politics so
he's slowly being deflated i still
doubt that we will ever again see donald
trump do
a full actual press conference before
leaving office
where he takes questions and he's not
even going to be punished for it by his
followers because they will say he's
right not to take
questions the media colluded with biden
and they're all against him and they're
fake why would he give them the ratings
of letting them ask him questions so
that's what they'll say
trump will sort of fade away and he may
i mean listen we we may
after christmas as has been suggested he
may just leave dc and that'll be it
no appearance at the inauguration would
not be at all surprising although
for for optic's sake i would be
fascinated to see donald trump at the
inauguration
of president joseph r biden jr we've got
a great show for you today today will be
like a friday show
because it is the last show of the week
we are off tomorrow and friday for the
thanksgiving holiday but we are here
today one more show and then we'll be on
a little bit of a break
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money helping the
environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the
coverage of other shower heads the water
sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it only took a few minutes
to set up really easy and it's been a
totally different experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get completely
rinsed off
so i was actually amazed that it's only
using about half as much
water nebia also offers a number of
shower accessories like
shelves and curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head
the shower head starts at just 199 but
the first hundred people to go to
nebia.com
pacman and use the code pacman will get
15 percent off
site-wide
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right welcome back to the show let's
uh let's hear from some folks
it is the uh i guess sort of
thanksgiving edition
of live calls hitting us earlier this
week
because we will be off on thursday and
friday for
the thanksgiving holiday we are taking
calls via discord
at davidpakman.com slash discord
d-i-s-c-o-r-d
and we have uh all sorts of different
people
who are interested in chatting today
let's start
with andrew from miami andrew from miami
you're on the air
hi david how's it going can you hear me
yes i can
great i was wondering what your opinion
was of remember when bloomberg ran in
the democratic
primary yeah he threw in like a billion
dollars or something right
i think it was um i think it was a 150
or 200 million certainly
oh no i think reporting from washington
post new york times said it was around
900 million oh well
maybe it is yeah i'm not saying you're
wrong i had not heard that number but
it's conceivable
sure and then during the actual
presidential election he only threw in
about
100 million in one state um
i found that interesting because he said
that trump was an existential threat to
that democracy and didn't and i think he
said he was going to do
like everything possible to get biden
elected and he didn't
i mean listen 100 million is nothing to
sneeze at obviously but for a guy
with his wealth he could certainly have
have put in
way more for sure and i think that's why
people are saying things like
you know eat the rich and whatnot but i
mean i also saw even on the democratic
side
like obama only came out around two or
three weeks before the election
and then afterward he has this book tour
where he's on every major news station
isn't that pretty interesting yeah i'm i
find the obama thing less surprising i
mean i think during the primary
obama's approach was clear which was
he's not going to get involved close to
the primary or before it's
decided because he wants to be able to
credibly support whoever the nominee is
and if he ends up
you know endorsing someone during the
primary who doesn't end up being the
nominee it could just hurt his ability
to campaign for them i do
you're right that obama was only on the
physical campaign trail for a couple of
weeks
but i think a lot of that was that
there was really no in-person
campaigning being done on the democratic
side for a while because of the virus
he you know obama did speak at the dnc
which was remote i i that that's less of
a flag to me the the bloomberg thing
it's just like he was obviously just
dishonest about how involved he was
going to be
and helping the eventual nominee win he
just lied
right definitely cool yeah thanks for
taking my question i appreciate it
all right andrew from miami great to
hear from you uh we are taking calls
via discord at davidpakman.com
discord let's go next to uh let's go to
skyler from new york
skyler from new york you're on the air
can you hear me sort of you're you're
kind of cutting in and out
how about now is it any better that is
better awesome
um well thanks so much for calling me um
my question
is how do we dispel the notion that
progressive policies cost the democrats
in the house and the senate
well who who's arguing that
like for example uh the moment that you
know the associated press called the
election for biden you've got john
kasich on cnn
saying that you know they almost cost
the democrats the election and that
biden needs to cater to
the center which is what most of america
is despite
every exit poll showing overwhelming uh
majority favoritism towards these
progressive policies like whether it's
legalizing marijuana or raising the
minimum wage or
even fox news showing like 70 percent of
people supporting a government-funded
health care system
yeah well so i think you so what's
interesting is the one example you cited
of people saying that
is a republican anyway so i don't really
worry too much about that i mean i think
i i've heard a little bit of a debate
within the left
about did the democrats run too far left
or too far right
in the house and senate i don't think
there's one answer to that i think that
we need to stop that
that general question is the wrong
question because there are districts
in which it is completely reasonable to
run more to the left
and then there are districts and seats
where that would not
work uh as much as i dislike joe manchin
in west virginia who is the most
conservative
democratic senator i have not seen
any data that suggests a progressive
running in west virginia
would win because west virginia
democrats are different than democrats
in other places so i just think it's an
it's too simplistic of an argument
i think you have to be looking more more
specifically at individual races and
states and realizing that
country of 331 million people that's
this size there's no
anybody who says the problem is
democrats ran too far left
or the problem is democrats ran too far
right it's too simplistic of an
assertion
hello oh i think you got me remuted
there somehow are you there
uh yeah i did get renewed sorry about
that no problem
um yeah i mean like i just saw a clip of
jim clyburn saying that defund the
police cost
jamie harrison's seat despite uh the
widespread
protests in black lives matter and that
whole movement
actually is what initially saw jamie
harrison
uh surge in the polls yeah not only that
i mean
defund the police was something that was
mostly pushed on democrats by the right
there are some democrats talking about
defund
most are not most are talking about
reform reorganize restructure rethink
and i i was one of them i mean the
defund the police was mostly
a smear in the sense of what was
actually being proposed at the national
level
i know and why is it that you know
democrats are unable to work outside
these right-wing framing and talking
points like
uh anybody that actually takes like a
nuanced perspective on this
understands you know what what you mean
when you say something like defund the
police but
it just seems like republicans have a
more effective way of
uh you know smearing and grifting their
base and controlling the branding and
the messaging and the democrats
are often playing defense instead of
getting out in front of these things i
basically agree with you
but the the one thing you did say which
i think is a fault of the left
is you say you know most people
understand what defund the police really
means
i've been saying for a while if you
don't mean defund don't call it defund
call it what it what it actually is and
that that i think is a fair criticism
uh but but for the most part again it's
been a smear from the right attributed
to democrats and
uh you're thinking of all the right
things you you were just muted
i don't know i don't know how this
caller keeps getting getting muted i'm
not muting them
but i appreciate the call and um i hope
to hear from you again that's
uh a server mute kept appearing on that
caller
and there's only a few people with the
permissions that would make that happen
so i think we should try to understand
uh why why that
that was happening that's very very
strange okay
let's go next um
let's go to tebow from belgium
tebow from belgium you're on the air hey
david can you hear me yes i can where in
belgium are you calling from
i am calling from ghent oh beautiful
beautiful city i've been there oh nice
yes
it's a large students population over
there so i'm still studying uh
veterinary medicine
uh so that's why i'm there now ghent is
the one that has the
trolley right
trolley yeah isn't there isn't there
like an elevated
subway that goes down the streets in
ghent or is that antwerp now it's all
blending together
i think you might confused with antwerp
okay all right well i apologize for that
no problem so i wanted to ask you
because i have heard
um i've been following your channel for
a couple of months right now
and i was wondering because you have
always stated that your position
on trump getting into prison after his
presidency
is very minimal but after i
i've been following the news for like
the past couple of years about trump and
the difference i am noticing
uh with european countries is that you
have one
major news channel like fox news
enabling his presidency and his
misinformation and his life yeah and
that is not something we see here
in european countries where um opinion
shows
uh don't really exist or not in a
such a big fashion as it does in the us
so i'm thinking trump has had a
precedent right now
um by committing crimes inside the white
house outside the white house
and he can get away with anything he
wants but the president has already said
so if he runs again in 2024
or if a more intelligent person
a rich guy with more intellectual
capabilities than trump
runs in 2024 the president is set and he
can
expand his crimes he can expand his
behavior
so i think it is important that if trump
uh is proven to be guilty of crimes
after he leaves the white house
he should be prosecuted and if judge con
thinks he should he should go to jail
then i think
you should not um prohibit that or
think of it as he is a past passion a
former president so we can't do that
oh i i completely agree with you what
i've said is
i don't believe trump is going to prison
i
your analysis is spot on donald trump
has debased
the office of the presidency he's shown
that even the checks and balances
that the founders put in place never
assumed
someone who would flout these norms
the way that donald trump did and i
believe that what donald trump exposed
is that our checks and balances are not
nearly as rigorous as we imagined them
to be
your assessment is 100 correct i just
don't believe there is really any
appetite at the top level in the united
states to jail former presidents
period that my i was making a prediction
not an analysis your analysis
is completely correct oh okay and i'm
also like worried because
a lot of democrats i feel like in the us
are feeling like
democracy is saved right now but if
trump is going to start his own news
channel
yeah and the republican party by the way
doesn't exist anymore it's not a trump
party
so if they follow his like trump news
and all his new opinion shows he will
launch and
the wild spread misinformation then it's
gonna be
like 2016 all over again i feel like i
think you're right
and uh with the issue of whether the
republican party is now simply
the trump party i think it remains to be
seen i think
i do think that if donald trump
relatively
quickly uh goes back into obscurity
which he may
we just don't know yet i think you will
very quickly see a lot in the
of people in the republican party just
sort of pretend it never happened
and go back to talking about the debt
and and
kind of the way the republican party was
before trump if trump remains
present if he starts a news network or
whatever the case may be i think it'll
be handled differently
i think we just have to wait and see on
that
yeah but the fact that like 80 percent
of uh republicans
already think that this election is
rigged yeah also says a lot about
yeah they're still republican or just
that doesn't bode well that doesn't bode
well i agree with you
okay yeah thanks for taking my call i
really appreciate it all right my
pleasure great to hear from our friends
in belgium belgium
is a one of my favorite places i've
visited i have to tell you i've been to
uh brussels bruges
ghent and antwerp and all um
all amazing places really really great
places
let's go next to um
let me go to kenny in phoenix kenny and
phoenix you're on the air
uh good morning david how are you i'm
good how are you doing
good i'm eating breakfast right now oh
all right what are you having
uh some bacon some eggs and toast with
butter oh my goodness turkey bacon i'm
sure right
no sir unfortunately the full thing okay
very very good
oh yeah um so i wanted to ask um i
actually had a conversation with a
really good friend of mine
that i've had since uh early childhood
last night
um i had a conversation with him about
politics and we've never talked about it
before
uh i consume a lot of political content
and um you know he i think this kind of
ties into the whole uh
like deprogramming thing um so i was
talking to him and he uh
he thoroughly believes all the talking
points but
he doesn't consume any media i asked him
about it he hasn't really
watched any media he doesn't really read
any news
um he knows all this stuff through word
of mouth which is
kind of scary now when you say word of
mouth do you mean like literally
do you mean people at work telling him
or do you are you including social media
in word of mouth
um i think social media actually might
play a role right what's up
yeah i i was that's that's i think the
key thing because
at this point you know when we talk
about like fox news for example
only a few million people are ever
watching any a particular episode of fox
news this country is 331 million
people but the point is fox news has
agenda setting power and then
you see the stories repeated on facebook
and on twitter etc and that's where it's
being that's where it's being repeated
and that makes sense
yeah um and so so we were going back and
forth about the
election fraud thing and i kept trying
to i i don't think he really understood
um
you know how all this stuff works and i
think you know i think a lot of people
don't
yeah so like what what do you think and
it was it was so hard to to you know be
polite right because as someone who's
paying attention to this stuff it's like
it's
it's it's really frustrating you know so
i guess like what i just wanted to pick
your brain and see like what do you
think maybe some strategies might be to
like uh i guess like
calmly uh you know attack this i guess
i mean with someone that's that
uninformed and who's basically just
getting
what other people they know are sharing
on facebook for example they're not even
necessarily it's not even about getting
them to look at different news outlets
because they're not even looking at news
you have to start really softly with
where where did you where did you learn
that
and getting them to say and then say oh
and
how do you know that that's trustworthy
you know they say well my aunt aunt
beatrice shared it on facebook
okay well what what does aunt beatrice
do for work
oh well i don't know sure she works in a
factory oh all right so clearly she got
it from somewhere she this wasn't her
research where did she get it well i
guess i don't know where she got it okay
well
you know you can you can find out for
yourself there are primary sources on
this stuff
you've got to start getting them open to
the idea
that they may be hearing things that
aren't true but it is
it's really tough it's very very
difficult yeah
it can be really hard when uh like one
thing i think a lot of people on the
right tend to do
is like they'll uh do all their own
research
and they'll end up at a lot of very
interesting conclusions
right but research often just means you
look at articles on breitbart you know
yeah pretty much right and then it's
like well i can come back at them with
10 articles that say hey you're not
right man
yeah well you can't believe everything
you read on the internet it's just like
oh man
this uh it yeah it can be a little
stressful i mean the problem is that
with a lot of these things
you you know there's this false notion
that it's up to sort of like opinion
like for example
does cutting taxes for the rich help the
economy that's an empirical question and
we can look in history
at changes to tax rates and then the
associated changes in gdp employment etc
there's a lot of people who
unfortunately are in the paradigm of
well i don't know because you know the
nation says one thing and breitbart says
a different thing and then tucker says
one thing but then msnbc says something
else
you can go and look at economic
papers that are peer-reviewed from
you know groups of economists and
actually
answer that question but the problem is
a lot of people either
aren't aware or don't know or or have
the interest in actually doing that but
a lot of these things are really they're
knowable they're not really opinion
they're not really up for debate
yeah so i guess um i guess like a big
first step
is gonna be trying to i guess get
uh like get these people to understand
that academics have
um what is it like uh
like they're held accountable it has
accountability yeah and i think the
first step is just getting people to
recognize
that there's limits to what they know
you if once people recognize
that their their their knowledge is
limited and there's more out there
that's step one and
unfortunately a lot of people are either
just naturally
in curious or just busy living their
lives where they take that thing they
see on facebook and that's as far as
they go and that's that's that's not a
good
recipe yeah that makes sense
kenny great to hear from you i really
appreciate it
thank you have a good one all right
we're going to take a quick break if
you're holding to talk to me please
don't hang up because we're going right
back to the phones momentarily
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always struggling
to find the time
check out one of my all-time favorite
apps
called blinkist blinkist lets you
consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect if you don't have
enough time
to do all the reading you want to do or
if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video
welcome back to the david pakman show
all right we are taking calls via
discord at davidpakman.com
discord and we are doing this a little
bit earlier this week because
we are going to be off at the end of the
week due to thanksgiving
let's go next to amanda amanda who's
holding on to talk to me what's going on
amanda
amanda you're on the air what's going on
i can hear you amanda what's going on oh
oh hello okay perfect um so i
have a question and i wanted to know
what you think about
the lawsuits that are coming uh to trump
over the next couple months
or years once after he leaves office
i think that the most likely um
way this will go is that trump's
businesses are going to be investigated
and this could mean anything from money
laundering
to tax evasion to everything in between
i think it's quite plausible that
trump's businesses will have to pay
some fines we've already seen you know
trump university was disbanded and had
to pay a fine
trump's charity had to dissolve because
of its
using the money as a personal slush fund
and and i
i think that we will see that i even
think it's conceivable that there might
be
associates of the trump organization the
business
that could face criminal charges i don't
know that anybody's going to do any time
but basically i think that that's as far
as it's going to go amanda that's my
sense right now
okay and amanda is gone amanda amanda
left and that is it
from amanda that's too bad okay let's go
next to
eduardo from brooklyn eduardo from
brooklyn you're on the air
hi david hi how are you i'm good yeah
big fan uh thanks for doing this thank
you
uh quick question for you though is um
so as the vaccines kind of become a
little more
readily available um i was wondering is
there going to be sort of sort of like a
like a paperwork that you have to show
that you've been vaccinated or like
some sort of badge or whatever i assume
so yeah
we've already heard uh so the airline
qantas has already said they will be
requiring a vaccination certificate
after a certain point if you want to fly
with them
ticketmaster has said they are building
infrastructure
so that um any any sports or
concert venue that wants to sell tickets
with them will be able to require
a vaccination certificate in some cases
it's a vaccination certificate or
a negative test within you know a
certain amount of time before the event
i um i am hopeful that some american
airlines
will say after a certain date you need
a vaccination certificate i i don't know
if it will be administered at the
federal or state level
there will be people eduardo who will
say this is
mandated vaccination and of course it's
not it's only
if you choose to avail yourself of
certain private business services
you need to be vaccinated and i think
it's going to be necessary to get more
people vaccinated 40
reportedly don't want the vaccine and
that's a real problem
do you do you reckon though that if uh
like
that can be sort of like extended to
sort of
like a localized situation like bars and
restaurants and stuff like that
it certainly could be but my instinct is
that
you know an individual bar or business
is unlikely to pursue that that that's
my sense
i think it'll be you know airlines
maybe some schools um and
uh you know employers could do it if
you're a really big employer
like a walmart for example you could say
listen we don't want
our employees falling ill nor our
customers getting the virus from
employees
so after a certain date if you want to
work with us you you need to have a
vaccination
that's certainly something a private
employer could do
i'd be shocked shocked if like
individual restaurants did it
sure yeah i mean for that we need a
vaccine for us anyway we need the
vaccine first and uh you know hopefully
we are we are three weeks from it
fair enough uh thanks david and keep
doing what you do all right eduardo from
brooklyn
great questions uh vaccine talk love it
love the vaccine the vaccine is coming
and
uh that is you know that is something
we're all going to have to contend with
let's go to i believe this is kendall
from is it san mateo
it's sort of too long for me to see i
know it's kendall though
can you hear me david yes i can it's uh
san marcos texas oh san marcos okay very
good
yeah sorry i'm super white so i always
pronounce the san marcos
um no so my question was
is with um i had it pulled up here
with the gsa um
uh the gsa announcing that they'd be
letting the transition go
through um have you noticed i just
wanted to do your take on the
notable further breakdown what seems of
trump's psyche as he's been tweeting
because
after the gsa uh tweet or sent out the
letter
and trump said he would be allowing the
gsa he's been
retweeting just some really strange
things from like actors especially
he's been he looks like he retweeted
randy quaid like
four times listen what's going on with
trump is
he is furious that the attention is
shifting to joe biden as it should
because trump has given up on the virus
and biden is now running a coronavirus
task force
joe biden's building a cabinet joe biden
will soon be president
and what's what you are seeing are the
last
gasps of trump's narcissistic ego
and so he just can't stop and the
my guess is that trump tweeting that
he's allowing the transition to go
forward even though he still thinks he
won
i think that that is likely to be as
close as we get to a concession from
donald trump
but i would expect him to continue
tweeting for a while
when the election is certified on
december 14th
he may start doing less of it and we may
even see trump just kind of go off to
mar-a-lago around christmas time and
never come back to dc
but this is all ego driven what you are
seeing right now
right i it was just when i woke up this
morning i always you know i check i
have google read me the news and then i
go through twitter
and i always check and see if if trump
has done something
incredibly stupid and all i see is is
randy quaid
yeah it's uh there's no i don't know
that there's really any rhyme or reason
sometimes trump will do 80 retweets in
the middle of the night
sometimes he'll be very quiet trump
hasn't taken questions
from the press for for nearly a month
and i would be i would expect that to
continue for a while quite frankly
but we're just going to have to deal
with and deal with it until he finally
goes
okay well thank you david and if you
ever end up in san marcos
i know you're a big uh foodie so if you
ever end up in san marcos definitely try
um a cafe on the square it's a
restaurant downtown
it's real good all right very good i
appreciate the recommendation
give a good one all right you too take
care uh there we go
checking in there from uh from texas
a lot of viewers a lot of viewers in
texas let's go next
to taffin from california that is not a
name i've seen before taffin
oh no yeah my i don't know where my
parents got their name from
interesting you've never asked i mean i
mean actually i do know where it's from
but it's like such a silly story like
but um no but uh
my question is um this is something i'm
kind of noticing and it's kind of like a
question that's raised in my head that i
think
might actually have some implications
for the republican party
okay but um i recently saw this video of
like a bunch of um
like trump supporters in georgia and it
was some like rally or protest or
whatever
and one of the guys got up and started
shouting about how they were going to
destroy the republican party
for betraying them right and this is
something i'm starting to think
like see more and more and i think it's
more of a trend now
where i'm seeing more infighting in the
republican party rather than actually
like
exploit going towards any like democrats
and stuff
and looking back i think one of the
things that made the republican party so
strong
was their like coalition building and
what i'm thinking
is that well do you think that there's a
possibility that like
how radicalized that the republicans and
trump have made the base
could actually start like making blow
back against the republicans
because we're seeing more and more that
a bunch of like uh republicans
like obviously they've supported some of
this stuff but they can't support all of
it
and the moment you know that they go
against it like we saw with tucker
carlson the people started like um
slamming back against them and uh do you
think that could start making some like
blowback or repercussions to the
republican party i would love to think
that the answer is yes
but i think the most likely scenario
is that once trump is gone and joe biden
is sworn in
there's this phrase return to the mean
and
i think that we are going to see
republicans basically go back
to where they were before trump which is
democrats really are the enemy you'll
still have these
fringes of the republican party that
will say the problem is the republican
party
isn't right enough or whatever the case
may be but i think for the most part
you'll see republicans going back to
exactly what they were where you see
the low-tax pro-business conservatives
uh allied
with the evangelicals allied with the
libertarians
all united that democrats are really bad
people really bad they're socialist
communist etc
and i don't think that the fracturing of
the republican party that you're seeing
right now
is going to persist now i could be wrong
and if it does persist it could be great
for the left
but i'm not optimistic i think the
republican party will go right back to
what they were before donald trump
yeah you're probably right i just got
excited seeing that in georgia because
the runoff's coming out
yeah i think i i also saw people um some
some
republicans saying we need to punish the
republican party by not voting at all in
georgia
in the georgia senate i thought it was
gonna which sounds
democrat but i could see them like just
not voting exactly
exactly and i hope that happens because
it could actually i mean the polls are
really tight in both of those races
they're essentially statistical ties
if if a million more democrats register
and a million republicans decide not to
vote or something you know
whatever numbers that alone could flip
the results and give democrats the
senate which would just be amazing
no yeah yeah so i guess at least in the
short term there's some benefit to be
made out of that
yeah there may i do think republicans
will go back to what they were
but in the next two and a half months
there may actually be an advantage to be
gained from uh
from from the chaos and and let's hope
that that's the case
okay yeah well thanks for taking my
question david all right my pleasure i
appreciate uh
very much appreciate the phone call uh
that is going to do it for calls
for today as always you know my deep
apologies to everybody i was not able to
get to but they're
it's a good problem to have that there
are more
callers than time for calls hope
everybody
in the us has a great thanksgiving i'll
take a few audience questions after the
break and then we'll be back at it very
strongly
at the start of next week the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an
example you don't need insurance it's
only 99 bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me is a really
perfect fit for me
and my medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
okay let's get to our last set of
audience questions before the
thanksgiving break just a reminder we'll
be off on thursday friday
for the thanksgiving holiday the show
isn't cancelled we'll be back monday and
just taking a couple of days off first
question
today via you via the audience
can donald trump beat joe biden with the
faithless electors
scenario that is being drawn out so
i want to explore this now i want to say
up front
this is 99.9 percent pure fantasy
i'm going to give you sort of the two
versions of this
that that exist and we'll talk about why
neither is going to happen so the the
way that the election works
is that each state holds an election
massachusetts gets a result
and florida gets a result and california
gets a result and
if donald trump wins florida florida
sends republican electors
to cast florida's electoral votes for
donald trump
and if joe biden wins massachusetts in
california as he did massachusetts and
california have
democratic electors uh chosen by the
party
uh tend to be very loyal to to the party
um cast their electoral votes for joe
biden so
the first faithless elector scenario is
the simpler one
which is you have electors that revolt
for some reason they don't have faith
in the candidate that their state has
voted for so a democratic elector from
massachusetts for his example says
i don't care that i'm a democratic
elector i don't care that
the state voted for joe biden i will
vote instead
electorally for donald trump instead of
joe biden now that would be one ele one
elector that needs to do that
it is always very unlikely that you're
going to have any significant number of
those there were two for donald trump in
2016. remember donald trump
won 306 electoral votes but in the end
got 304 because of two faithless
electors okay
this time because joe biden likewise has
306 electoral votes
you'd need 36 electors to be faithless
and flip
to get to a tie in which the house of
representatives controlled by democrats
would vote
or you would need 37 electors to be
faithless and flip
to hand donald trump an electoral
college victory it's a fantasy
it's simply not going to happen uh
period
and um it is you know
that that is just simply not going to
happen so then there's this other
idea and this was written about before
the election
and i covered it extensively and we've
talked about it a few times
which is a strategy in which if you have
a state
with a republican legislature and a
republican governor
that biden won they could choose
to send republican electors anyway
to vote for donald trump even if
joe biden won the popular vote in the
state
it's not going to happen and the reason
that's not going to happen is as i
mentioned you need both
the governor and the legislature to do
it
if you have just the legit so first of
all you're only looking at states biden
one
because you need to flip those states
you look at states biden one with
republican
legislatures you first need republican
legislatures willing to do it
and then in addition if you get a
republican legislature willing to do it
you need a republican governor who is
not willing to veto it and there simply
aren't enough states
meeting these characteristics uh to make
that a possibility
and it it even if they were willing
morally even if they had no problem with
this ideologically or whatever the case
may be
um they're not going to be able to do it
now just
for the sake of exploring imagine that
somehow they figured out a way
to manipulate electors or convince
electors or bribe electors or whatever
the case may be
in order to flip the results for donald
trump what the hell happens
internationally
what the presidency would be seen
as an illegitimate presidency
internationally
this would be different than you know
you think back to the year 2000
and florida and hanging chads and the
idea of george w bush is an illegitimate
president
um it did not impact you know countries
accepted that george w bush was
president i believe that if donald trump
were somehow to figure out a way to use
this elector scheme to reverse the
results
um i i believe that he is seen as a
completely illegitimate president
internationally in a way
we've never seen before but we don't
even have to hypothesize
we don't even have to wonder because
it's not going to happen
joe biden's going to be sworn in on
january 20th
the only scenario that could delay
but not stop this is one i'm going to
talk about
a little bit later on in this segment
next question that came
in david for all of the failed talk
about a civil war
after the election results what could
actually start
a second american civil war so
let's talk about this in in a couple of
different ways
first of all a lot of times when people
talk about an american civil war or the
division of the united states into two
countries
they are talking about red states blue
states
and the difficulty of that is that
the geographical boundaries of what red
state blue state would be
um are relatively uh loose in the sense
that
many red states still have 30 35 40 even
45
democratic voters many blue states still
have 30 35 40 45 percent
republican voters so this idea
you know it it's not a requirement for a
civil war
that the lines be super clear if you
look at italy in the early 40s
you had this north-south thing but the
north was filled with those sympathetic
to the south and vice versa you can look
at sort of modern civil wars syria and
ukraine
they are more really sustained uh
sectarian insurgencies than clear civil
wars the way we had
the union in the confederacy um in the
american civil war
the other really interesting thing to
consider is that just
for the sake of a thought experiment if
we want to think about a second american
civil war along confederacy union lines
the confederacy is completely
financially
unsustainable and we've talked about
this before
in the united states you have all of
these federal programs
into which states pay and out of which
they
receive benefits they receive money the
blue states
dramatically subsidize the red states
and so
you have a lot of states in the u.s
overwhelmingly red
states run by republicans that were it
not
for being subsidized by money from blue
states they wouldn't be viable
and what you would have if you were to
divide the country
in the imaginary second civil war into
factions that sort of line up with
civil war union and confederacy
if there were to be a separation the
confederacy
would be in 2020 com they would be
bankrupt
very very quickly um and it would be a
desperate situation there so it also
is uh practically speaking um not going
to
it doesn't it doesn't make any sense now
in terms of
now that we've gotten all of that out of
the way what could really get the united
states to boil over
maybe not into what we would call a
civil war but sustained and major
sort of sectarian uh violence and
and fighting one of the things that
corporations and the
financial sector and others are
uh really effectively doing in the
united states
um is they have created a situation
where
a lot of people are just kind of happy
enough being able to be on the couch
watching football on sundays
and um living their lives not that
everybody's lives are perfect there's
tons of hunger poverty everything in the
united states but there's enough people
due to cheap stuff from
china and credit card debt and all of
these instruments that are available
you've got a lot of people who
their threshold for when they're going
to go out in the streets and do anything
is really really high and it creates a
natural disincentive for people to do it
at the same time low wages
the low savings rate of the united
states the financial instability that so
many people experience
also makes it tough to go out in the
streets because
you need to buy food the next day for
your family and if you miss a day of
work and it's unpaid and you're not
gonna be able to do that
and you need to be able to not have your
car repossessed
so that you can go and drive and get the
food the point
is this is a system that perpetuates
itself
the status quo perpetuates itself by
keeping
keeping people sort of just happy enough
that they would re need a really high
bar to be met before they would go out
fighting for anything
and at the same time you keep them in a
precarious enough position
that they can't afford not to work for
very long
that is how you preemptively and
systemically suppress an uprising
so i don't know what the answer is about
what it would take for something to boil
over to be almost like a civil war
you also don't need everybody you don't
need everybody
either fat and happy or in squalor
to have enough people to really cause
chaos there's no doubt about that
but it is actually difficult to imagine
what would rise
to that level um i think that you know
if donald trump were to figure out a way
to steal the election i think you would
see protests like we have not seen
for i don't want to say how long decades
for sure
would it rise to a civil war i don't
even know i'm curious to hear from you
hey david between the legal challenges
and the not conceding
and claiming he won and lawsuits and
elector ideas
what is donald trump's actual endgame
here does he think he will be
inaugurated to a second term
i think the answer is no i think at this
point donald trump knows he's not
getting a second term
and for me you know there's been a lot
of focus about
trump's lawsuits having the goal
of throwing out so-called illegal votes
or getting a recount that changes the
results
i think if we want to for a second uh
believe that there's some bigger
strategy here and there may not be but
let's imagine there is some bigger
strategy
the more likely strategy the more likely
to be effective strategy here
would be that donald trump is merely
trying to get a court
to prevent a state from certifying its
election
if you can prevent state legislatures
from certifying
the election results you then can create
a situation
where state legislators get to pick
electors this is part of 3 usc section
2. now this is different than what i
talked about
in an earlier segment where i said
you're not going to get enough faithless
electors
you're not going to get willy-nilly
states to just send different electors
but there's this scenario where if you
can actually delay certification
state legislatures get to appoint
electors
and for me if there is a strategy
and i don't know that there is these
people have shown themselves to be
incompetent everything they're filing
is being thrown out if there were a
strategy
it would be that i still think it's
unlikely because i don't know that i see
a court
staying in other words pausing
certification by any state
uh in such a way that it will go further
than roughly december 14th which is when
that electoral
vote is set to happen i don't see that
happening courts have been moving very
quickly oftentimes we'll have a lawsuit
and then two days later
the court throws it out courts
understand the time sensitivity of this
um so given that i don't think
trump really believes he has a shot at
overturning the election results
it seems to me that this is either just
donald trump's delusional narcissistic
ego
who can't admit that he lost even if he
sort of knows he knows he's going to be
pushed out
he simply can't admit it and he says
file every lawsuit you can do everything
you can
it might simply be that it could be
donald trump planning to undermine joe
biden not only now but through his
presidency
and this is just part of it never
admitting that he actually lost
it could be that donald trump is trying
to hand joe biden the most chaotic
possible situation he can
on january 20th and continuing to
further
uh these lawsuits is part of that and it
could be that donald trump is simply
trying to smoothly transition
right into some kind of media project
which has been hypothesized by many
trump wants to do
some kind of challenger to fox news some
kind of you know outfoxing fox news with
some kind of trump news network
all of these things i find myself saying
okay we'll deal with that when when we
come to it if we do
after donald trump has left office on
january 20th but i don't see any end
game beyond that
and if you really think donald trump is
doing this because he thinks he's going
to get a second term
i want to hear from you i just don't see
it we have a great bonus show for you
today
after which we will be off thursday and
friday for thanksgiving
i will be back with you on monday monday
have a good holiday
if you're celebrating be safe very
important be
safe
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 less water but with a stream of water
that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman steadymd lets you maintain a
meaningful
long-lasting relationship with a primary
care physician
who you can meet with any time over
phone or video chat you don't need
insurance it's only 99 dollars a month
with no
other fees or co-pays visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes you can try it for
free and get 25
off a subscription by going to
blinkist.com
david pakman